Hi Leute, ich bin hier im Zeiss Museum
der Optik mit der Photonik Akademie 2016.
Hier können Studenten eine Woche lang Unternehmen
aus dem Bereich der Photonik, also der Wissenschaft
rund ums Licht, besuchen und viele spannende Experimente ausprobieren.
Ich hab hier in der letzten Woche schon ne Menge spannender Dinge gelernt
und ich erzähl euch gerne mehr am Ende des Videos. Aber jetzt geht's erstmal um ein
Highlight der Veranstaltung: Ein Vortrag von
einem Nobelpreisträger. Um genauer zu sein
Prof. Dr. Stefan Hell, der 2014 den Nobelpreis in Chemie gewonnen hat.
Wie er das genau angestellt hat
und was man für einen Nobelpreis eigentlich können muss, das finden wir jetzt heraus.
Bei dem Problem in diesem Video geht es um Mikroskope. Die Werkzeuge, die es uns erlauben
in kleinste Welten einzutauchen und ohne die es so viele Dinge in unserem alltäglichen
Leben einfach nicht geben würde. Die ersten Mikroskope waren noch recht simpel gebaut und konnten
nicht mehr als eine 50-fache Vergrößerung
darstellen. Doch mit der Zeit wurden Mikroskope
immer komplexer und erhielten mehr und mehr Elemente,
sodass man immer kleinere Objekte beobachten konnte. Aber eins nach dem anderen.
Gehen wir einmal zurück. Um genau zu sein
ins Jahr 1873. In eine Welt in der Autos gerade
erfunden werden und man von Quantenphysik
oder elektronischen Computern noch nicht einmal
träumte. Dort beschrieb der Physiker Ernst
Abbe erstmals eine fundamentale Grenze der
Mikroskopie, nämlich die Auflösungsgrenze
mit der man kleinste Teilchen
gerade noch so voneinander unterscheiden kann.
Heute ist sie als Abbe’sche Formel bekannt.
Diese Formel sagt im Grunde genommen aus,
dass alles, was kleiner ist als die halbe
Wellenlänge des Lichts, mit dem man es beleuchtet,
nicht zu erkennen ist, weil es vom Licht nicht
getroffen wird.
Das bedeutet für uns: Egal wie gut das Objektiv
eines Mikroskops das Licht bündelt, egal
wie scharf das Glas ist, die Physik unseres
Universums hält uns davon ab mit sichtbarem
Licht Dinge zu mikroskopieren, die kleiner
sind als ca. 200 Nanometer. Und das ist echt
schade, weil viele spannende Dinge in unserem Universum  kleiner sind als 200 Nanometer. Verschiedene Viren,
einzelne Moleküle und auch unser DNS-Strang
zum Beispiel, all das sieht unter einem Lichtmikroskop
einfach nur verschwommen aus.
Über Einhundert Jahre lang galt das sogenannte
Abbe-Limit. Forscher entwickelten andere Verfahren
wie die Elektronenstrahlmikroskopie oder sie pushten
die Grenzen, indem sie die Wellenlänge immer
weiter verkleinerten. Und auch wenn diese
Techniken toll sind, so haben sie doch ihre
Grenzen. Zum Beispiel kann man damit keine
Lebenden Organismen mikroskopieren, weil sie
beim Vorgang durch die Strahlung oder ein
Vakuum abgetötet werden.
Eine andere Entdeckung, die in der Zwischenzeit
gemacht wurde, betrifft den Teil eines Mikroskops,
der leuchtet. Anstatt kleine Teilchen, also
zum Beispiel Moleküle, von unten mit Licht
zu bestrahlen färbt man sie ein. Und zwar
mit einer Lösung, die von alleine leuchten kann.
Fluoreszierende Stoffe nennt man das
und die kann man zum Beispiel in manchen Soft-Drinks vorfinden.
Hält man so eine Flasche an einem sonnigen
Tag ins UV-Licht der Sonne, dann fängt ein
Stoff namens Chinin in der Flasche von sich
aus an zu Leuchten, weil der Stoff vom UV-Licht
angeregt wird. Das löst unser Problem aber
immer noch nicht.
Auch der selbstleuchtende Stoff ist unter
dem Mikroskop noch total unscharf. Aber an
dieser Stelle kommt der junge Physiker Stefan
Hell ins Spiel. Er hatte eine geniale Idee.
nämlich die, dass man einzelne Moleküle
an- und ausschalten kann. Wie einen Lichtschalter
kann man bestimmen ob das Licht an sein soll
oder nicht.
Stellt euch ein paar Moleküle vor, die wir
beobachten möchten. Alles, was in diesem
Kreis hier ist können wir nicht wirklich
sehen. Es verschmilzt zu einer unscharfen
Ebene. Das ist aber nur der Fall, wenn alle
Moleküle gleichzeitig leuchten.
Wenn ich jetzt mit einem grünen Licht Moleküle
anschalte und mit einem roten Licht alle anderen
drumherum ausschalte, dann schaffe ich es
nur wenige Moleküle gleichzeitig zum Leuchten
zu bringen. Und das Licht dieser wenigen Moleküle
kann ich dann genau zuordnen und ein wesentlich
schärferes Bild erhalten. Das war der Durchbruch:
STED heißt dieses Verfahren und wird an solchen
unglaublich kompliziert Aufbauten durchgeführt.
Hier wurden die Laser durch Trockeneisnebel
sichtbar gemacht. Und das Ergebnis ist nicht zu verleumden: Aus solchen Bildern… wurden solche.
Dieser Durchbruch sollte Stefan Hell und den
zwei Kollegen Wiliam Moerner und Eric Betzig
2014 den Nobelpreis in Chemie bescheren. Nur
leider kam der Erfolg nicht sofort. Von der
ersten Veröffentlichung der Idee bis zum
Nobelpreis vergingen etwa 20 Jahre.
Anfangs glaubten viele Forscher nicht an die Technik und die meisten Wissenschaftsmagazine weigerten
sich seine Publikation zu drucken.
Doch irgendwann gewann das Verfahren doch
die verdiente Anerkennung und ist heute ein
wichtiges Instrument für Forscher weltweit.
Und das ist das wichtigste Kriterium für
einen Nobelpreis. Der Schwede Alfred Nobel
schrieb in seinem Testament, dass jedes Jahr
die Menschen ausgezeichnet werden sollen,
die den größten Nutzen für die Menschheit
gebracht haben. Als Belohnung erhält man
zu gleichen Teilen die Zinsen des Vermögens
von Alfred Nobel aus diesem Jahr. Das beläuft
sich inzwischen auf etwas unter 1 Millionen Euro.
Außer der Voraussetzung, dass man noch leben
muss um den Preis zu erhalten und dass man
seine Entdeckung in irgendeiner Form publiziert
haben muss, spricht nichts gegen eine Nominierung
für einen Nobelpreis. Und falls euch das
nicht genug motiviert, dann hört euch doch
mal an was ein echter Nobelpreisträger zu
seiner Motivation sagt.
- Also meine Empfehlung ist dass man immer das tut was einem Spaß macht.
Wenn man etwas von Herzen tut, dann bringt man auch die Energie auf das richtig zu machen.
Auch mehr Energie auf, wie das, was nötig ist. Um einen normalen Job zu machen.Man macht da einfach mehr.
Und das "Mehr machen" und das "Besser machen" ist natürlich eine Voraussetzung zum Erfolg.
- Gibt's schon ein konkretes Gesetz, dass Sie als nächstes brechen wollen?
Wenn ich das wüsste und im Kopf hätte, würd ich's Ihnen natürlich nicht sagen.
- Ah ok. Alles klar. Vielen lieben Dank.
- Danke.
- Gerne.
Wenn euch das Thema Licht und Laser interessiert,
und das tut es bestimmt, wenn ihr das Video
bis jetzt gesehen habt, dann interessiert
euch vielleicht auch die Photonik Akademie.
Hier können Studenten jedes Jahr eine Woche
lang den Bereich der Photonik besser kennenlernen,
spannende Experimente durchführen und Experten
aus der Branche treffen. Ich war jetzt die ganze Woche
dabei und hab das Ganze mit der Kamera begleitet und ich muss sagen es war ne ziemlich coole Erfahrung.
Wir haben ziemlich viel erlebt und spannende Experimente gemacht.
Die Photonik Akademie gehört zum Photonik Campus,
einer gemeinsamen Initiative der Photonik
Branche und des Bundesministeriums für Bildung
und Forschung. Mehr Informationen, und einen
tieferen Einblick bekommt ihr auf der Website
des Photonik Campus. Den Link dazu findet ihr wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, dann gebt mir doch einen Daumen nach oben und schreibt einen Kommentar
Und ansonsten vielen Dank für's Zuschauen, bis zum nächsten Mal. Euer Cedric
Hauter rein :)